.
THANK YOU.
AS WE SAID A MINUTE AGO, THIS IS
NOT A SURPRISE.
THE LAW, THAT MATTERS BECAUSE IT
IS THE SUPREME COURT WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT, THE LAW BEHIND
THE ROE V. WADE DECISION IN 1973
WAS SO SHODDY AND RIDICULOUS
BECAUSE ABORTION IS NOT
MENTIONED IN THE CONSTITUTION,
NOT EVEN ALLUDED TO, THAT A LOT
OF PEOPLE FIGURED OUT A LONG
TIME AGO THAT IT WOULD AT SOME
POINT BE OVERTURNED BECAUSE IT
WAS TOO ABSURD TO CONTINUE.
SO A LOT OF STATES HAVE BEEN
PREPARING FOR IT, MORE THAN A
DOZEN HAVE TRIGGER LAWS THAT
WILL TAKE EFFECT NOW THAT
ROE V. WADE HAS BEEN OVERTURNED
AND A LOT OF THEM WILL OUTLAW
MOST ABORTION.
EVENTUALLY ROUGHLY HALF THE
COUNTRY IS EXPECTED TO IMPLEMENT
A SIGNIFICANT NEW RESTRICTIONS
ON ABORTION, AND THAT MATCHES
PUBLIC OPINION POLLING ON
ABORTION WHICH IS TO SAY A LOT
OF PEOPLE DON'T LIKE ABORTION.
IF YOU LIVE IN NEW YORK CITY YOU
MIGHT NOT KNOW ANY OF THEM BUT
IF YOU LIVE IN MISSISSIPPI YOU
KNOW QUITE A FEW.
THE POINT IS, PEOPLE WILL GET TO
LIVE WITH THE LAWS THEY WANT.
HOW IS THAT BAD?
THE STATE OF MISSOURI BECAME THE
FIRST STATE TO BAN ABORTION,
ERIC SCHMIDT ATTORNEY GENERAL,
WE ARE HAPPY TO HAVE HIM JOIN
US.
ATTORNEY GENERAL, THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR COMING ON.
WHAT IS THE STATE OF ABORTION IN
MISSOURI NOW?
>> MISSOURI BECAME THE FIRST
DATE AFTER THIS BE A DECISION TO
EFFECTIVELY END ABORTION FOR
THIS HAS BEEN WORKED ON FOR
DECADES, PEOPLE PRAYED UP ON
THIS, IT'S A LONG TIME COMING.
THANKFULLY PRESIDENT TRUMP
APPOINTED THREE SUPREME COURT
JUSTICES KNEW THAT THE ROAD TO
DECISION, THE DATE WAS ISSUED
WAS ON A COLLISION COURSE WITH
THE CONSTITUTION.
AND WE SEE THAT HERE TODAY NOW.
THIS DECISION WILL BE DECIDED AS
IT SHOULD'VE 49 YEARS AGO TO THE
STATES.
MISSOURI INTERESTINGLY IN 1825
WAS THE FIRST AID TIPS FORMALLY
PROHIBIT ABORTION FOR THAT WAS
THE LAW OF OUR STATE UNTIL
ROE V. WADE AND NOW WE ARE BACK
TO WHERE SHOULD'VE ALWAYS BEEN.
IT'S A BIG DAY AND AS YOU
POINTED OUT, IT IS A BIG DAY FOR
DEMOCRACY, FOR THE VOTERS TO
HAVE A SAY AS OPPOSED TO THE
NINE UNELECTED JUSTICES READY
NINE YEARS AGO THAT DECIDED THIS
FOR EVERYBODY IN THE COUNTRY.
AND I THINK WHAT YOU ARE SEEING
NOW WITH THIS NIGHT OF RAGE THAT
HAS BEEN TALKED ABOUT, THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT HAS NO
INTEREST IN CONDEMNING IT, THEY
HAVEN'T DONE ANYTHING TO STOP
IT.
WE'VE SEEN US ASSASSINATION
ATTEMPT OF A SUPREME COURT
JUSTICE.
THIS IS GOING TO CONTINUE.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT IS WAY
MORE INTERESTED IN SEEKING THE
FBI ON PARENTS WHO SHOW UP TO
SCHOOL BOARD MEETINGS UNDER THE
PATRIOT ACT AND THEN ARRESTING
FOLKS INTIMIDATING SUPREME COURT
JUSTICES.
THIS IS OUT OF OUT OF THE BANANA
THIRD WORLD REPUBLIC BUT
THANKFULLY THE RULE OF LAW WAS
BUTTRESSED TODAY AND MISSOURI
WAS THE FIRST STATE TO TAKE
ACTION.
I WAS PROUD TO DO THAT IS THE
STATE'S CHIEF LEGAL OFFICER.
>> Tucker: I'M GLAD THIS IS
BACK IN THE POLITICAL ARENA
WHERE IT BELONGS, WHERE VOTERS
CAN DECIDE.
WHAT EFFECT, PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO START AFFIRMATIVELY
DEFENDING ABORTION AND NOT
HIDING BEHIND STUPID SLOGANS AND
EUPHEMISMS.
IT'S A CHOICE, IT'S A
HEALTH CARE PROCEDURE, IT'S A
HUMAN RIGHT.
WELL WHAT IS IT AND WHY DON'T
YOU TELL US WHAT YOU ARE FOR IT?
YOU LOOK FORWARD TO THE
COMPOSITION?
>> ABSOLUTELY, THAT IS WHERE
SHOULD'VE BEEN ALL ALONG.
49 LATE AS WE HAVE A RESET AND
THE PEOPLE GET TO WEIGH IN, WHAT
WAS ALWAYS INTENDED AS
OPPOSED TO ROE V. WADE WHICH WAS
MADE OUT OF WHOLE CLOTH.
>> Tucker: YEAH, IT'S AMAZING.
THEY HATE DEMOCRACY LIKE THE
DEVIL HATES HOLY WATER.
IT'S AMAZING TO SEE IT